[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host ken coleman ramsey
personality host of the ken coleman show
best-selling author of the book paycheck
to purpose is my co-host today as we
talk about your relationships your
mental health your jobs your career and
your money it's life on the radio we're
going to talk about you right in front
of you it's a free call at
eight two five five two two five triple
eight eight two five five two two five
bailey is in oklahoma city hi bailey
welcome to the ramsey show
hi david nice to talk to you sure we're
glad you're here how can we help
i have a question um
me and my husband made it through uh
baby set three um on the 3b we got our
house
paid 20 down
um and
we you know had after having paid off
almost 20 pounds 20 000 and consumered
it
um i just had a baby um our third child
um but i had a lot of medical
complications and i'm still not
completely clear
um so i'm getting those uh they're
starting to come in
and so my question is how
best to go about paying them down
um since we have our emergency fund um
i'm still i still haven't received all
of the bills
that will be coming and then of course
i'm still like i said not completely
clear so i don't know what this is gonna
mean for me medically long term
okay well the uh
you know you got to pay the bill
obviously um
i'm assuming insurance is paid all it's
going to and the bill you're getting is
after insurance has done its part right
that's right and i get a 20 discount
because i'm employed by the hospital
well that's wonderful okay so how much
debt how much medical debt have you got
well thus far it's not um it's on a
ton so far um right now we're sitting
about five thousand dollars but that's
before
um getting an ic bill
and then i'll also um we were able to
stockpile a lot of cash while i was
pregnant but how much um
well well it's our emergency fund oh you
have your emergency fund and you said
you were saving for a house and you
stockpiled cash or the saving for the
house was the amer was the stockpile
well we bought the house so that's
right okay so
you have money in addition to your
emergency fund when you said stockpiled
we don't
okay how much is in your emergency fund
um it is about we had it at twenty
thousand dollars and then um
now if my husband was in a bad accident
i had a cash flow and a car as well
um didn't have insurance on the car
um we
did um they
the company paid for
the call pace about 50
they gave us 5600 for the course
but we were a little bit short of that
we had to get a car
um that would fit all of our car seats
safely i have three kids and they're all
in car sheets
um so we ended up spending about five
thousand dollars so we're about fifteen
thousand dollars um in our emergency
fund
okay so write a check and pay your five
thousand dollar medical bill
okay so i should i should um pay like as
they come i don't need to wait until
they yeah um
there's nothing to wait on there you owe
them you might as well just pay it right
and what's your household income
it's i just got a twenty thousand dollar
range so what's your household income
about 140 okay well you could probably
cash flow the five grand without
touching it and you need to you need to
get the bills paid and get your
emergency fund rebuilt
okay just start concentrating on this
okay
and let me give you a hint the car that
you had before it got totaled
would fit the car seats
it doesn't
it didn't fit the car seat so what that
means that you did not need a car that
fitted all the car seats
you justified this this was not an
emergency purchase this was a choice
we had a baby we had a baby i know right
but i mean what were you planning to do
if he hadn't totaled his car
we were we were saving money
to buy to cash flow cars no you weren't
you had an emergency fund you didn't
have any money saved above the emergency
fund i've asked this question four times
you told me you had an emergency fund
and you put everything else down on the
house you know 20 000 and you took money
out of your emergency fund to upgrade
your car after your car was totaled and
use the baby as an excuse to do it so
i'm not letting you get away with that
one that's rationalization okay now i
don't mind if you upgrade your car but
let's not take it out of the emergency
fund and let's cash flow out of the
hundred and forty thousand dollars and
get the five thousand dollars paid as
quickly as you can just on a practical
note you can get a fifty six hundred
dollar car that will fit three car seats
you can yeah it's you really can't yeah
it's very possible very impossible
people do it all the time
and um well i mean
um actually you you you could about
three months ago but now you can
i still i still submit that you can i'm
kidding i know he is but i'd say this
bailey let me encourage you on this i
mean you've got some unnecessary fear
here the same discipline the same focus
that allowed you to build up money to
pay for a house to to build up a 20 000
emergency fund will allow you to pay off
the bills on 140 thousand dollar income
nothing to be scared to get to five
thousand dollars paid off build up your
emergency fund and then get on with your
life the thing you've got to do out here
folks and i'm just not going to allow
you to do it because i had to stop it
and if you're going to win you got to
stop it you cannot use these life events
as
um rationalization as
as as a reason to violate good
principles
you know it's like okay i'm trapped i
have to go into debt no you don't i'm
trapped i have to use my when you're
purchasing a car and it's an emergency
that's highly unusual almost always when
you're buying a car especially if you're
upgrading an existing car
that's by definition not an emergency by
definition so um
whatever it is you're doing just don't
rationalize that because here's the
thing you drain the stinking emergency
fund down you have a real emergency now
you got no money and you're right back
to being normal and broke again so you
have to guard that stuff and go okay
it you know is the new mattress an
emergency is the bass boat an emergency
answer no
no no no no no no well the old mattress
is bad i don't care save up and buy it
it's an upgrade okay i don't care i
don't like my old couch i don't care
i don't care it's not a freaking
emergency my mother-in-law's coming over
i need a new couch it's not an emergency
tell her to stay at the hampton inn no
it's not an emergency you know you
buying a couch for someone else to sit
on and be impressed with
by the weekend because it suddenly
occurred that she's going to come visit
you it's not an emergency but we do this
stuff we all we create these this
hyperbole this drama in our heads that
causes us to get off the tracks and run
down the thing so
here's the here's the thing
medical complications are an emergency
yes
that's that is an unexpected event that
is not an expected event uh if you
weren't down to 15 and you had 20 you'd
be less worried about taking five out
for the medical that's correct so you
know thank god you didn't take 15 out
for a better car
because you had to have more car seats
oh and i have to have an airbag and i
have to have a
oh
the automatic doors are an absolute
necessity i don't know how people around
the world
deal with life without automatic doors
unless you're driving your fun vintage
car then it's worth it well
says the guy who drove his vintage
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality joins me
this hour open farthest today as my
co-host i'm sorry open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
you're out of here after this hour see
everybody it's been great toss you
uh alex is with us alex is in nashville
hi alex welcome to the ramsey show
hello gentlemen thank you for taking my
call i'll try to be concise i work in
i.t since covet overtime has been
readily available my base salary is 40
000. i've been able to make about 65 000
since covid
annually for the past two years i've
used that surplus to pay off debt and
cash flow a wedding i found out today
our rent is going up by 500
and i'm wondering if i should
do the budget for our rent as we plan to
move or not move based on overtime or
based on my base salary
wow
uh
if the overtime is going to be there i
don't mind you doing the point of the
the whole thing there's no magic to the
fourth of your income going to housing
the the whole point of it is don't be
house poor whether you're renting or
whether you own
if your house payment your rent is a
huge percentage of your the money you
have available then you don't have any
money left after you pay it
it's kind of a simple big number concept
it's not a splitting hairs difference
here
but that's a lot of overtime
are you going to continue to work that
kind of overtime for a while to come
just for another year i should have my
student loans paid off in the next six
eight months
um so i'm looking forward to pay to pay
that off that's the ultimate goal yeah
um from a numbers perspective our rent
is going to go up to 2500 a month if
they don't come down we've submitted
like
like a basically you know on we're
trying to negotiate so our rent is
either going to go up to 2500
bring home per month between my
girlfriend and i and we get married in
october we bring home about seven
thousand dollars a month uh net so
that's you know
it's a little higher than 25 percent so
i don't know if we should move to some
place cheaper yeah you're sure what we
should do you should if you can
and and the reason is simple um
the the rent
is you know it's patience
you're not investing in something here
you're parking your butt somewhere until
you get some money and buy a house
and the more you pay in rent the long
the less money you're gonna have for
other things like getting out of student
loan debt and like uh buying a house
and so you know anything i can do to get
cheap cheaper rent any time i'm going to
try to do it within reason
and so um yeah yeah i mean
uh
rents in nashville have gone through the
roof
because a stupid mayor raised the
property taxes through the roof
the uh
comrade cooper that i was hoping you
were gonna put that out there yeah oh my
god congress destroyed the economy over
there but the not destroyed it but it
just hammered the businesses and
everybody else and so those high
property taxes are now being reflected
in your rent because the landlord's
costs went up
and so you get to pay the taxes is what
it amounts to
um
alex what do you do in it what's your
position so i basically help our company
keep people working from home so we have
thousands of people that work from home
when those thousands of people have an
issue they call a number i talk to them
and work then help them stay online so
internal tech support would be one way
of saying it correct uh what's your
goals in technology do you see a ladder
do you have something you aspire to in
technology
so i was in the midst of making a career
transition before the overtime became
available so i'm just using the overtime
as a vehicle to pay off my debt
ultimately my goals are not in it okay
well i i reason i ask that is i think
dave's right i i would lower my rent and
i would also pretty quickly uh get out
of this overtime reliance and move
yourself up to professional ladder so
we're increasing our income uh as well
as decreasing that rent as we're saving
for a house so uh sounds like he's got a
good plan yeah that's exactly what i
would do yeah because here's the thing
the rent is
i did that when i when sharon i first
got married a million years ago um
we rented a our first property that we
rented was very expensive
and uh i was actually um
i thought i was so proud because i was
renting the taj mahal right you know it
was great it was an amazing property and
um i went to visit my old elementary
school principal now that i had come
back home to nashville oh yeah a local
boy does good just just dropped by the
shirt i had a job i had a wife i thought
life was good and she said where are you
living and i told her and she said
good lord what are you paying and i told
her and she said well that's dumb why
are you paying that much in rent
yeah really
we literally moved out of that property
at the end of the lease six months later
and
cut our rent in half
in half that feels good so uh different
numbers than alex is dealing with but it
was a different world in those days but
i mean we moved to a one-bedroom
apartment uh
in a not so great complex uh to get and
cut our rent actually is more than in
half
that's pretty bizarre when you think
about it but but that was a place to
camp until we saved money to buy
something temporary and so it was it was
a complete waste
to rent to spend a whole lot of money on
rent
spend as little money as you can on rent
and yeah so yeah that's that's the
premise i'm coming at this so alex
you're getting the same advice that my
own elementary school teacher
uh our school principal gave me uh when
i went back to visit i would have loved
to have been there when she dropped that
on you
she uh was um
classic no-nonsense
classic no-nonsense point evelyn hyde oh
mrs hyde everybody needs some mrs hyde
in their life
she was a wonderful lady that's cool
just an absolute jewel all right let's
see here earl in philadelphia hi earl
welcome to the ramsay show yeah how you
doing dave a little nervous right now
talking to you but
no trouble shut up how can we help
yeah um i'm a government employee and
i'm looking to possibly retire um this
coming year
and um currently right now i have
in my tsp about 1.8 million way to go
whoa
you're a rock star man
yeah yeah um
and and with the government you don't
feel you don't sound real impressed with
you i'm impressed with you
i don't know it's having that much money
it still makes me a little nervous um
but um and it's traditional but um
yeah with the government they provide
you with like a um you know financial
courses and um one of the guys who gave
the course i guess he's like a financial
guy
and i just said let me just talk to him
and he mentioned something about a fixed
index annuity
and i know how you feel about annuities
but this fixed index annuities um you
know he basically gave it a spin where
you know when the market goes down it
doesn't really go down and
i don't know i just don't really feel
too good about it and also too i'm i i
did talk to one of the smart investor
pros
and i'm going to talk to another one
good you know they interview them but um
i i just want to know how how do you
feel about i mean i don't know much
about fixed index annuity i did a little
bit of research but i just want to hear
it from you okay um well basically what
we're talking about is an indexed
annuity that has a has a floor to it
it's not gonna go below a certain return
probably five percent or six percent or
something like that and it's probably
indexed typically it'll be off of
something like the s p 500
right right in indexed means it's not
fixed index means it follows an index
okay so like have you got uh your your
tsp in the c plan
some of it yeah okay so the c is an
index
that's an index so you have an indexed
investment now if you have money in the
s plan that is an index it follows a
small cap index
uh and so all you're doing is we'd find
a a group of stocks that the weighted
average of those stocks represented
index so an s p 500 is an index and so
it follows that the the problem is not
the index the pro or indexing the
problem is not the floor the problem is
that the annuity fees are double what
you are what you get with a mutual fund
and his commissions are 4x what he would
get if he sold you the same mutual fund
same index
without without it being in an annuity
and so this guy is this guy wants a
commission you need to run
okay
okay i kind of got that feeling
but i said you know let me talk to
someone but i i just didn't feel right
about it um trust your feeling yeah yeah
your feeling was right but that's that's
all it is it means it's gonna it's a
conservative way that gives you a floor
but you're paying dearly for it it's not
the end of the world it's not an
absolute horrible product it's not as
bad as like whole life or something like
that but it's uh it's not as good as
just a group of mutual funds with your
smart investor pro which will have much
lower fees they make much less
commission on you doing that you got a
much better situation you got two
million dollars
you need to learn to trust your gut you
have a really good gut instinct
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsay show
we're so glad you're with us kaylee is
on the line in provo utah it says on my
screen kaylee that you are debt-free
congratulations
thank you thank you it's an honor to be
here today well honor to have you how
much did you pay off
i paid just shy of forty one thousand it
was like forty thousand and nine hundred
and thirty two dollars way to go
very cool and how long did this take you
this took me 15 months okay and your
range of income during that time
so my range of when i started it was 50
000 and i was able to double my income
within that time good lord what did you
do
oh dave do you know what's so
interesting when i started this journey
i was like i need to make more money to
make this happen and within a month job
opportunities were coming at me
and i was literally able to double my
income
what were you doing before and what are
you doing now
so i was a campaign manager for a grill
company and now i'm the vice president
of marketing for supplement company here
in utah of course you are oh my gosh
that is so amazing and all it was was
you looked up and said i want more money
i'm ready i was ready for it you know i
want more money and i went and got me
some
shocker shocking strategy right yeah you
look forward to i'm surprised you aren't
sitting at home waiting on the
government to send you some instead you
just went and found you some money i
want some money and i'm going to go find
some i like you that's amazing how old
are you
i'm 33. cool you got a degree in
marketing
you know what i didn't i went to school
uh in political science i thought i was
going to be a lawyer but didn't go that
route okay so uh ken coleman wants to
know
how you did this okay you you just
decided but i mean how did you go
identify the place and go get the job
tell people how that's done
so it's really interesting i mean
i feel like i've always known my value
but i just kind of took what was given
me and it really i know it sounds so
cliche but it genuinely was a decision
it was like okay if i need to make this
x amount of money to be out of debt in
this time this is how much i'm gonna
have to make and i only applied for jobs
that were gonna pay me that
and guess what happened people people
responded and it worked all right so
what about
so what about the imposter syndrome that
didn't affect you at all you go for a vp
of marketing position
oh i feel it every day but you just you
you fake it till you make it right there
you go you stepped right through it so
you're telling me you didn't need a
marketing degree to be a vp of marketing
no so i but i worked in marketing for
about seven years prior to get so you
know i mean it was on the job experience
you didn't have to go back to school to
double your income you just went and
doubled your income yep learned on the
job
that's correct yeah apparently you're
good at marketing and you marketed you
well yes i like it this is a powerful
you're great okay so tell us how you
started this whole journey this ramsay
stuff of getting out of debt 15 months
ago
so i tell you what my dad preached dave
ramsey when i was a teen and i'm not
gonna lie to you dave i i rolled like
every time yeah i was a cuss word at
your house yeah oh yeah he gave us a
total money makeover book you know every
year for christmas um so for a while i
just tried it the kaley way which was
wait until i had whatever left over my
paycheck to pay it off which you know
how that worked it didn't so i just
started with baby steps and i'm telling
you i mean
it was a boring life rice and beans no
traveling saying no to going out with
friends and but within 15 months i'm i'm
free and so it was worth it
and i have my six month savings and it's
just everything's just falling into
place
so your dad's got to be like running
around the house cheering oh he was the
first person i called and he's like you
need to get on the dave ramsey
but he did he just he it was the dave
ramsey method baby steps and the total
money makeover so wow i'm so proud of
you well done i know he is that's so
cool very cool all right what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is double your income what else
be consistent and i know this is the
whole thing right live like no one else
today so you can live like no one else
tomorrow or in the future that's real
don't who cares what people think how
you live you're gonna be free and it's
it's worth it the boring haul is worth
it
so did uh did any of your friends like
to give you the eye roll like hey she's
kind of lost it
oh 100 oh when i'm sitting here eating
ramen and they're like you want to go
get sushi on my camp not in the budget
this month
getting out of debt getting out of debt
i like making gold i like it
okay so you went and i you just applied
for the job and walked in and they gave
it to you or did you know somebody or
how did you get how did you get your
foot in the door where you got this new
job
so i did know someone and i started out
as a brand manager and i mean i worked
my tail off
and
i am the only woman hey happy
international women's day i'm the only
woman
in an upper management role there as a
vp and
yeah i had to work but i did know i did
have some connections and really just
put myself out there how long were you
in the brand manager role
um for about a year and a half
wow so when you started this you were
already in that role
yep
and then you just went you went for that
you went for an internal promotion then
yep yes sir okay i got it all right okay
good well but again uh not only are we
hearing an amazing story here of how she
worked the baby says but now this is
somebody who saw a ladder dave and said
i'm going to go step on this ladder and
i know if i climb
i'm going to be able to climb into
something to make the money i want to
make and you got in and now you're the
only female in leadership good on you
yeah that's fantastic that's exactly how
you do it i don't think they care if
you're a female or not i think they
notice that you do the freaking job well
yeah yeah oh 100 that's right you're a
rock star that's what it is
good for you wow well done well done
touchdown all right it's kaylee in provo
utah we got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you this time you got
to read that dave ramsey book not i roll
it and because that's the next chapter
in your history baby it's coming you're
coming you're gonna be a millionaire now
and then also gonna send you a copy of
total money makeover so you can abuse
one of your eye rolling friends with it
and uh keep keep the keep the cuss word
dave ramsey thing moving forward it's
part of my brand so uh good stuff i'm
proud of you count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
i'm debt-free
yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
i feel like she yelled that so loud the
three two one that the phone muted
itself i think yeah it was that was that
could have been a lot of passion a
little stage gate there yeah oh my gosh
you know what the thing i love about
that though is
it's not just uh positive thinking like
i can speak my way into something that's
not true but you know zig ziglar used to
say he goes well positive thinking won't
guarantee you're going to get there but
negative things will guarantee you're
not that's true and so she just says um
i mean your whole thing on paycheck to
purpose is you know i'm going to look
over there and i'm going to reach over
there and grab that and make it mine
that's right that's right i'm going to
use a connection which she did and and
these are this is how we get
opportunities in life doors open for us
we don't have to always kick a door down
that's been romantic and there's no
lightning strikes there's nothing it's
not random no she reaches out to a
friend she gets in
and then she moves up bust it she gets
in and she crushes it she wins she's
noticed gets noticed then the next
appears exactly you got to win where you
are you're not sitting there whining no
you don't have any women in leadership
that's right no she went and he became
the woman in leadership she went and got
her done that's good you know you don't
have anybody with a southern accent well
you get get your butt up off the couch
and go do something that's the thing man
so you know whatever it is that you're
whining about she didn't there's not a
whine in her body she doesn't know how
to whine no i mean she she saw the level
and she went after and here's a point
that you need to understand about your
opportunity to move up in this world
certainly now more than ever before
right this second is now it's now and
people listen leaders need someone that
they believe will help them win
and if you just show up
you show up early you have a smile on
your face you do the job they've asked
you to do you do more than they ask you
to do you look for ways to help them
serve them serve the team have you
follow all in ad just be valuable and
here's what happens you will rise to the
top you can't you can't keep from
happening because most people are takers
if you'll add value exactly instead of
taking value well you know people walk
into a job and they look at the places i
wonder how much they'll pay me
why don't you figure out how much you
can add value and they will gladly give
you money
this is how this world works but being a
dadgum parasite
man she is awesome yeah got me fired up
i like it this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the ramsey show
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is a brand
new book is in pre-sale right now it
will actually come out a little bit
later here in april we just got the
shipment in though so we actually have
them in stock we're ready to go when the
book is ready to launch
and we've sent them out to the bookstore
chains and everything so they'll be in
the stores on time which is kind of a
good thing given the paper problems and
logistics problems and all that stuff
out there so yeah supply chain issues
but hey we got books so we're excited
it's going to come out on time the book
is own your past change your future
if you've ever heard dr john on the dr
john dolone show or heard him on here
and thought man if i could just sit down
with him
for a few minutes one on one and have a
coaching or counseling session i really
think
i might be able to get a handle on some
of the things that happened to me in my
past and maybe move on with my future
let me tell you what that's what this
book is
it's like having a personal counseling
session with dr deloney
and you ought to sit down and do it own
your past change your future it'll make
you laugh make you cry it did me it'll
challenge you did me
and you take the steps he outlines and
take advantage of your free therapy
because if you pre-order it you're going
to get a month of free one-on-one weekly
therapy
from the folks at better health i mean
they are incredible this is an
incredible offer it's all including a 20
book purchase this is a bargain
yeah so check it out ramseysolutions.com
the book is own your past change your
future lisa is with us lisa's in
cleveland ohio hi lisa welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave thank you for having me sure
what's up
well um
i uh
was married for 26 years six kids um
i did uh we struggled in our marriage my
husband had a lot of his own struggles
and
so i found out about you and i started
to do the baby steps by myself
um got us out of debt um except for the
house and he had a lot of student loans
like a hundred thousand
and uh we just marriage kept struggling
so i finally filed for divorce um i
moved in with my mom and dad last july
sold the house on my own
um found a buyer gave him half the money
um
and then a month before our court date
in december he died of coven oh my
goodness
and i'm sorry
and
so now i have like this you know huge
chunk of money
i don't know what to do with it i i plan
on buying a house my parents were
actually gonna help me with the down
payment um now they don't have to um
and uh you know i wanted to take care of
the house
or he had no will so i was the
beneficiary the beneficiary on what
his life insurance is 500 000
so you're getting 500 000 and you got
the house money
and yeah and he had a 75 000 life
insurance with his work
how much was the house
uh we sold it for
220 225 but we had a hundred and from
our
equity line on it that had to be paid
off so you got like 600 grand or
650 000 bucks yeah and then he yeah and
he's got 40 000 that an attorney is
working on getting for me
and uh 30 000 in retirement and the
student loan was in his name
yeah so those are all
well they're forgiven if their federal
student loans are forgiven upon death do
not pay those yes yeah you'll have to
provide death certificates and you'll
have to go through
a myriad of uh
federal paperwork oh my gosh what a
horrible thing you're going through
yeah how old are your kids
the oldest is 29 and the youngest is 12
and i
i have the two minors and the college
kid with me
but we're split up into two different
houses right now
um i really want to get a home so we can
heal
and just move forward
um but i'm getting advice from
you know tons of different people don't
pay cash for a house don't you can
invest that
do you have a career a different thing
i'm actually um i'm waiting on my award
letters from social security for the
three miners and my plan was to
pay cash for a home and go back to
school full-time i want to go for
respiratory therapy
okay what price range home are you
thinking of
that's the hard part
that's actually what i'm asking you
everything in our area
seems to be in about the 250 to 300
range yeah okay so if you have if you
have 700 000 and you put 300 towards the
house
and you pay cash for it then you've got
the money to go back to respiratory
school and you put yourself on a really
really tight budget right
yes yeah that was my plan that's that is
my plan now let me let me give you one
other thing to consider
in this normally when i hear something
like this going on i tell people try not
to make big decisions for a while
yes because your brain is clouded 26
years of marriage now clouded by a
divorce that was underway
um and the
the trauma that goes with this you start
wondering if you did something wrong
deep down inside
the inner voices start speaking to you
you know all the stuff that normal human
beings would experience if they were
going through what you were going
through okay
and so
my proposal to you is is that no normal
human having gone through what you've
gone through in the past two years
uh would be thinking as clearly as
someone who hadn't gone through all of
those things agreed
yes that all of this damage and all of
this trauma and all of these problems
and the grief and the weirdness
of a divorce that's almost final but 26
years of marriage you're already
grieving the loss of the marriage in a
sense in the process of doing that and
then he dies oh my gosh it's like it's
like this is stacked upon stacked upon
stacked upon do you hear what i'm saying
out loud yeah so yeah it might not be it
might not be a bad idea
to rent something for six months and let
the cobwebs clear
okay
and make a better decision six months
from now
um i think the numbers you're giving me
sound okay and i don't hear anything
in the way you're discussing this your
sentence structure your voice tone
can she sounds like she's got her stuff
together right
so we got we got a mic problem in here
but anyway yeah i think okay that's okay
the uh uh so are you plugged in
um but anyway so yeah you sound solid
talking to you but i would be worried
if i were in your shoes
that i might not be making the most
clear perfect decision together
yeah
and so i i i it's okay to go rent you a
nice house for six months get all the
kids in the family together and you guys
just all
have a little a margin a little
bandwidth to just process this all this
pain
because your kids lost their dad
yeah yeah
and that's in this and they were already
gonna have a split family and they had
all that so they're traumatized
right
yeah i mean their relationships with
their dad were pretty strained before
this yeah and so they've got this weird
thing of gosh i wonder if
if you know they've got stuff running
through their heads and i i just yeah
uh
it would not be a bad thing
for you to wait a little while to make a
300 000 decision
but if but you sound like you can go
ahead if you want to i'm just warning
you
to be careful
and it's okay i want to give you
permission to take your time and i also
want to give you permission to ignore
any idiot telling you not to pay cash
for a house you have plenty of money
okay
the other thing i would add dave is take
your time on the respiratory therapy
school look at multiple options do your
homework what's that going to cost make
sure that's the right decision for you
because this is the same kind of thing
she's thinking about it in the future
very solid i feel she's very but if you
if you just picked that because oh i
think i'd be stable i could make some
money yeah that's a wrong choice that's
right so let us send you a copy of ken's
book from paycheck to purpose as well
and you can that's some of your homework
you can read through that while you're
making uh
verifying in a sense oh let me do this
too let's get let's get you the uh get
clear assessment i think that'll i'm
going to give you the get clear
assessment as well i want you to take
that assessment we're going to give it
to you all free
and um
maybe we can help you kind of make just
make sure your mind is real clear on all
of these career and house purchase
decisions
so
wow
weird thing oh my gosh wow heavy stuff
yeah
ken coleman good hour good hour to the
folks in the booth this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsay network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
that is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host ken coleman
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
career about your jobs about your
relationships about your mental health
about your life about your money it's
what we do right here on the ramsey show
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five michael's in
boston to start this hour off hey
michael how are you
hey miss randy i'm good how are you
better than i deserve sir how can i help
so i also had a quick question so i'm a
19 year old college student at the
university of new hampshire um i have no
college debt no debt at all
and i work a job during school and in
the summer so i currently invest like
quite a bit of my money and my question
to you is should i invest more now that
i have no debt or expenses or should i
kind of hold money and wait until i do
incur expenses later in life
what are you studying
uh homeland security and emergency
management good for you nice a fun
degree
and um how much money do you have in
investments
i have about forty two thousand dollars
in lessons cool and how are you paying
for college
i'm in the rotc program so i have a full
full ride for college good for you
fantastic thank you for your service yes
all right and um
the full ride is uh tuition and books
and board
uh yeah full ride for tuition full ride
for room and i get 1200 a year for books
okay all right very good very good
okay
um what is the money invested in
um so currently i have a vehicle so i
have a roth
i maxed that out every year when i can
and it's in a lot of etfs right now i
know you preach in mutual funds so i
want to try to etfs are fine there's
nothing wrong with an atf nothing wrong
with it that's a you know it's just a
way of getting diversification as long
as you just keep it simple and you're
not trying to day trade sometimes people
use etfs for day trading and i tell you
not to do that but if you're just
dropping it into an index fund like an s
p
etf that's fine just like buying an
index fund just about not a lot of
difference and so that's
that's probably that's okay so here's
the rule of thumb i use okay
i my goal for you
is four years from today to graduate
four years from today to graduate with
zero debt
that's job one
now we have a plan to do that called
rotc
right
sometimes plans go awry
i don't think yours is going to but it
could okay so before i start funding
roth iras that you can't touch until
you're 59 and a half
i want to make sure
that this sharp young dude i'm talking
to graduates
because you are a better investment than
mutual funds are
so in a pinch
i want you to be able to access this
money to finish school if something
blows up with with rotc and i don't
think it's going to but i just want an
insurance policy to ensure that that
happens because you got plenty of life
after you graduate to start doing
long-term investing
so if you want to dump it in etfs or you
want to dump it into a money market fine
as long as you keep enough in there your
main goal is this is a big old pile of
money to ensure that michael graduates
and graduates debt-free no matter what
happens out there in the weird world
that we live in now
if you do graduate like we think
rotc you go into the service right
yes sure i'll turn you in the national
guard right okay and then you would
you'd take a day job as well if that's
the case i guess right
uh yes i'm looking at a couple police
jobs okay all right cool
and so you get the day job and you've
got
let's call it 80 000 bucks in the in in
your mutual funds or in your money
market accounts because you just kept
plowing money into there and you never
needed any of it best case scenario
happened
uh oh darn
you got 80 grand
you can go you know move that towards
buying a house you can move that towards
making sure you have your emergency fund
if you change cities you can pay your
moving costs you're not having to run
around take some job you hate because
you're broke
right because when i came out of college
i had a dollar seventeen
i had to take a job
and so i took the best paying job that i
could get the paycheck the fastest
because i needed money and i needed it
right then and i'd like for you to have
this as a pad so
this is not about you investing for 60
years old you got plenty of times to do
that this is about you making sure that
the next five years of your life are
amazing and that includes graduation
taking the new job and settling in the
new city
and that's what i want him to do yeah
it's great advice dave what you just
laid out is a way for him to have
options as he's launches he can launch
so many different ways because he has
that financial pad i think it's a
brilliant suggestion for somebody that
age they just aren't going to have the
stress they're going to have a lot of
different ways they can go they can be
patient if they have to be patient to
wait for the right thing
so many opportunities uh by him sucking
as much money away he's gonna change
directions you can do a lot of stuff
you get when you've got you know 60 80
000 bucks laying around you can do a lot
of stuff and he's going to have that
much at the rate he's going way to go
wesley's in chicago hi wesley how are
you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
i wanted a call because
my cousin just started a
job at northwestern mutual and oh god
trying to get me
trying to get me to buy a
whole life
for
400 a month and you know i've been
listening to you for a while and i run
the numbers on the policy and i can do
much better investing that yes
you could do better leaving it in a
fruit jar buried in the backyard than in
northwestern
gross
and your cousin won't be in the your
cousin will be out of the business in
two years
okay so what they do they hire him to
get get to all of his connections his
natural market and then once he milks
his list he's done he'll run out of
things to do he'll be out of the
business now it listen whole life life
insurance is is the payday lender of the
middle class you stay away from whole
life life insurance and oh by the way
northwestern mutual is one of the worst
policies of all the bad policies
this is like below the suck bar
yeah i was thinking i was kind of
curious how do i go about
you know telling
him that i don't don't want to do that
because you know i know it's not going
to go well tomorrow it's not going to go
well because he's been trained to come
after your throat
with arrogance like you're an idiot
that's how you're gonna be treated
it's how they train their sales people
and so it's not gonna go well you're
just gonna have to smile and be kind and
remember this is your money you don't
owe him anything yeah
less is more here dave's right yeah
don't get into
you know i i don't think you're going to
convince him of anything except that
you're not going to buy that's good
don't try to talk him out of anything i
would just say you know i appreciate
this and i hope you do well at your new
job but i'm not interested in this
product i've done a lot of reading about
it and i'm not going to debate with you
you're my cousin i love you i do not
agree and i'm not going to buy whole
life and i'm sure not going to buy it
from northwestern mutual and i i you
know for you because you're my cousin i
love you i hope you do well but not a
chance i'm doing it and that ends the
conversation
he ain't gonna shut up there but that
should end the conversation now dude
please stay completely away from this
you're not gonna convince him
to quit his job all you can convince him
of is that you're not gonna buy that's
all you can do
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today i'm dave ramsey your host
thank you for joining us america it's
common sense for your dollars and cents
in a world where common sense is so rare
that having some is like having a
superpower
all right allison's with us in tampa
florida hey allison what's up
hi
pleasure to be speaking with you today
um
i'm calling because
i think i made the worst financial
decision of my life
i'm trying to get out of my timeshare oh
you did oh you made a horrible decision
i know i legalized legalized fraud
oh
where did you buy a timeshare
like what state yeah or what company
i bought it in california in california
what company
a wealth financial oh my gosh okay
oh how long ago did you buy it
um 21.
wow just had a weak moment huh
yeah and you know my fiance and i are
just now trying to stay for our first
home so it's really just like you still
owe money on this thing
oh yeah are you kidding me oh yeah no
i'm not kidding and i've really tried i
tried everything contacting them they
have reiterated to me many times they
have no deep buyback programs and i
cannot sell or transfer the loan to
anyone until the loan is fully paid off
that's true yeah
yeah
oh
what it's a horrible horrible industry
it's just the worst like i got the two
calls back to back i got a whole life i
got a whole life call and that now that
the next call has to be about payday
lenders i mean this is like the whole
life to timeshare to payday lenders
we're gonna have to get his blood
pressure machine oh man i'm so sorry i'm
healthy yeah you're just
how much do you owe on the stinking
thing
uh about 14k oh my gosh so what'd you do
go out there and stay like for free and
they put you in a room and wouldn't let
you out to your boat or how'd that
work um no we were at an amusement park
and they you know offered us a free
vacation which we got whether or not we
wanted to buy and i told him like my
boyfriend at the time
let's you know we're not going to do
anything um the guy obviously like was
very good at his job um he had made a
lot of promises that i'm realizing
aren't even true like for example if you
book with one of their
part
excuse me partners then you get a free
week every time you book with them so we
went ahead and booked
um december the end of september come to
realize now we don't get that three
weeks because they're not with that
company anymore you know things like
that so this is called a fraudulent
inducement yeah he he told you a lie to
get you to buy
so uh here's what you do and i i don't
know if this will work but it's the only
shot you got okay
okay getting out of these things is very
difficult you stepped into a bear trap
and it got you on the leg and getting
out of it by yourself it's hard it's
very hard and even with help getting out
of it's very hard
we
man it's it's a nasty filthy business as
you've already discovered yeah and i
have heard of the timeshare exit team
they're gone
they got run out they got run out of
business by the by
the washington attorney general and by
the way
yeah they're horrible i mean it was a
horrible mess they got they did a good
job they got 20 000 people out but they
got run out of business by the time
share business
they uh the legal bills they got sued 60
000 different ways and then they got the
timeshare business got the washington
attorney general after them and it was
just a disaster but for a while that was
a good avenue there is a couple of
groups that are still open doing exits
that are legitimate groups
they're legitimate companies that do
exits but the exit even using one of
these people is very difficult okay so
no guarantees but and they're not it's
not an endorsement i they don't work for
me they don't have you know they don't
pay me or anything like that there's a
company called the newton group
uh and they've actually been helping
some of the timeshare exit customers
that didn't get help because timeshare
went out of business
uh they're trying to help some of them
too but the newton group
at
timesharetruth.com and uh they've been
here to our offices we've met with them
i met with mr newton and with the
several of the lawyers on his staff
they're good people but uh they will
look at you in the face and say getting
out of these things is very difficult
but sometimes they're able to pull it
off
but no promises but that's what i tell
you timesharetruth.com
the newton group and i that that's the
best thing i can give you and other than
that just yell at the entire world don't
ever
go to a timeshare presentation under any
circumstances there's no reason there's
no free vacation that's worth putting up
with this crap these are low-class human
beings it's a low-class business it's
nasty it's filthy they lie it's
legalized fraud have i been unclear ken
well dave i was going to ask you to
expound on that thought a little bit i
don't think you've covered it from
enough angles quite frankly but i don't
want to criticize hate the timeshare
business yeah because they screw people
and i just can't stand when the
consumer's getting messed over it makes
me mad
so what if she can't get out of this
she's gonna write a check she has to pay
14 000 and then she's the proud owner
and then the stupid maintenance fees are
going to go up every year right and then
can she sell it it's like it's like it's
like a disease you can't get rid of oh
that's unfortunate
you can't you they're for sale on ebay
for a dollar ooh nobody wants them
uh-huh because you get the mail you get
the maintenance fees and the maintenance
fees go up every year
because these companies are just they're
just straight up scum it's just awful
i mean they all of them are engaged in
it it's just oh just
uh please please people
you know it's don't never never go into
the tiger cage
that's what i call when you go in for
the sales presentation yeah oh it's like
oh
the tiger has not been fed in four days
yeah but if you can sit in the tiger
cage and not get eaten for two hours
we'll give you a free disney vacation
yeah you know we'll let you go to the
water park for free if you can sit with
the tiger and not get eaten and he's
very hungry though we will tell you and
you sit in there with the tiger don't go
in the tiger they're going to win don't
go in they beat you down who do you
think you are tiger king stay out of
there man it's just don't do it stay
away from the tiger
stinking i'll eat you man it's
unbelievable we should do a hidden
camera thing where we put hidden camera
on me and let me be the most obnoxious
question ask her every time they put
some i throw a question back and we just
you could do that i could do it it would
be hysterical yeah be a big hit dave i
go in totally miked up you wouldn't
camera and i'd actually be the best
ramsey personality at being obnoxious i
drive
thank you dave that means a lot that's
like the line from christmas vacation
where wherever he says can you see all
right do you send george campbell in
there no no it's me are you seeing uh
delony in there no he would already be
psychoanalyzing he would have wanted to
get out and be hugging everybody and
rachel would make everybody their friend
i mean you would you or me we're the
only two they're left we have the
spiritual gift of confrontation that's
it well no we just stir up crap that's
what that's what i mean same thing and
so just just bugging them and driving
them nuts to watch the guy need an
antacid
by the time i'm done with him yeah you
know just like totally because here's
what they do what they do is it's high
pressure and they make you feel guilty
don't you're taking their freebie don't
you love your family yeah right you
don't love your family well
not apparently as much as you do don't
you love your phone i would thrive in
that environment
i would love that it would be so good to
expose the high school as the
investigative reporter yeah right
oh i may do that oh i don't know there's
a couple of these guys that i owe on one
or two right now i own a couple of licks
back there's i've bloodied their noses a
bunch of times but i'm not done yet
you're not
off the top ropes i hate those little
jimmy super fly snooker from the welding
it's just they david there's a body slam
because you know who it is they take
advantage of that you know they take
advantage it's old people most of the
time a lot the vast majority of people
get screwed with time shares are the
elderly they load them up from nursing
homes put them on buses and take them to
presentations oh yeah but they also prey
on people who actually are broke and
what they do is they put a twinkle in
their eye and they make them feel like
they can experience what the better half
is is living
the other half i'm telling you it is an
absolute uh manipulation too for for
folks like i wonder what the poor people
are doing yeah it's like hey for a
really good price you can live like
everyone
yeah you see what's going on there right
yeah it's fomo yeah yeah that yeah for
sure oh my gosh yeah and if you loved
your family
you'd spend time with them on vacation
we don't guilt trip here but i just want
you to know are you i just want to know
are you a good father
i just want to know do you love him
do you really think that works do you
love him simple-minded do you think i am
that's awful women you don't love your
children
no you look like a man that loves his
children
i mean you have to buy a time share to
prove it
prove your love
prove your love
it's not unconditional love it's time
share love
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
well yesterday i shared a huge
announcement with you guys if you didn't
hear we're taking our wealth build our
building wealth live
event on the road building wealth's a
really hot topic right now a lot of
people making a lot of mistakes around
it everybody's got an opinion about
crypto single stocks zero down real
estate gold
anything you name it people are doing
all kinds of crazy stuff to get rich out
there and uh we take we talk about these
topics and even more and we did it in a
big event back in january that sold out
in about 20 minutes here in nashville so
we're going to have about 2000 seats in
about six cities the first one we're
announcing is orlando we're going to go
on tour with this and ken coleman and dr
john deloney are going to come with us
as well we're going to add them into the
discussion and into your event uh ticket
and everything so you want to get signed
up for this uh these will sell out very
very very quickly these are small venues
we're not doing arenas we're just going
to do a couple thousand seats and so
they're going to be dinged and gone just
like that so it is rachel cruz george
campbell me ken coleman dr john deloney
building wealth live the first one we're
announcing we announced yesterday is
orlando on may 19th
if you're not in orlando stay tuned
we're going to be announcing the other
five cities soon trying to get them all
tied up and get them out here on the air
for you tickets start at just 25 you can
get a four pack so bring
if if it's you and your wife you and
your husband bring your friends
bring another couple with you only 60
bucks for a four pack you can't buy
pizza for four people for that it's too
good of a deal david okay it's too cheap
we should be charging yeah i wouldn't
have approved that yeah i have i i may
not have approved it but we're doing it
so there you go this is a great deal for
you guys i just want to get back out on
the road and see people again
we love doing events at ramsey we love
being out there with you guys all over
america we love visiting the great
american cities and seeing the great
american people and oh i can't wait to
get back what are the chances that we
get some mickey ears on you at this
orlando event if they come fairly low
that's why i thought okay well you're
telling me there's a chance no i'm not
thank you dumb and dumber no it's the
best line ever yeah uh tickets are 25.4
pack for 60 bucks orlando may 19th
ramsey solutions dot com slash events to
learn more our question today comes from
blinds.com they have a 100
satisfaction guarantee if you mismeasure
you pick the wrong color they'll remake
your blinds for free free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsay for the best
deal today's question comes from travis
in wisconsin i'm having a moral dilemma
regarding the job change i work as a
truck driver my current employer treats
me very well
the until recently the company covered
10 states with four drivers and 10
people in support positions the driving
staff is now
down to two people me and one other
driver a company that shares our
building complex has been recruiting
drivers and they approached me and
offered me a position that is 25 more
than i currently make i'd be home every
night and it offers a better 401k it
would obviously be a good move for me
but it would
[ __ ] my current employer to the point
where they may go out of business i have
to think about what is best for myself
but my decision will most likely
directly impact 11 other families at the
same time what is the right decision to
make well travis
the right decision is to do what is best
for you this is a very tough emotional
situation i get this call a lot dave
on the ken coleman show where people go
i love the people that i'm with they've
been good to me
but i know it's time for me to move on
i'm moving on to something that i know
is on purpose yada yada yada but if i
leave
i feel like it's going to hurt the
company and and what i have said not to
be glib and not to be insensitive but if
this man travis leaving this company
uh
will cause this company to go out of
business then they were going to go out
of business with him anyway one person
while it may do some harm
the company's got bigger issues than
whether travis is there they've already
been whittled down to the point where
it's just travis and somebody else so
going down with the ship here that's the
the old school metaphor is not honorable
it doesn't make sense you have to do
what is right for you and your family
this is an absolute no-brainer uh do
your best to transition out uh the
classy way but yeah you got to do what's
right for you it's not your problem that
the company has been crippled yeah
um but he's a good dude and i understand
the heart behind he's got a great heart
of loyalty but um
if if you stay if you leaving causes
them to go out of business they're going
to go out of business if you stay
without question
they're not going to if they're down to
one driver being there not being there
causes them to go out of business it's
too late it's over
so you don't you can't carry that
responsibility or that guilt because
it's not accurate
okay it's um yeah does it put them in a
hurt and are you kicking them when
they're down yeah a little bit and i
appreciate the the that that bothers you
that means you're a good person
so here's what i would do
to try to
you know to try to uh i guess
offset that a little bit i would go to
your future employer
and say
i'm not going to be able to come for a
little while what's the latest start
date you can give me because i
really don't want to mess these guys
over over here i want to i want to try
to help them make the transition and i
need to give them a super long notice
can you wait one month for me to come
instead of just two weeks
and by the way you you want me to come
because i'm the kind of guy that acts
this way so i'll act this way towards
you when i'm here i'm not going to mess
you over
so you know you don't want to hire
people that are going to cut your throat
and i don't like cutting my old guy's
throat over here i appreciate the offer
what's the latest start date you can
give me and if he gives you four weeks
out instead of two weeks out then you go
back into your current employer and you
say hey listen here's what i've
negotiated
i can leave tomorrow or i can leave in
four weeks if you'll increase my pay
while i'm here i'll stay four weeks so
you can get time to get some drivers on
and you get in a bl you know you get in
a hardcore recruiting mode and get you
some drivers in here
and because i love you guys and i don't
want to leave you in a lurch and so i've
negotiated it this way i am leaving
now
or two weeks or four weeks your choice
you need to give me a raise to stay
during that four weeks while you go get
drivers
and that's not unfair that's very
reasonable and you know if you did that
with me
um i'm probably going to go ahead and
set you free even if it hurts not
because i'm mad at you but just because
i've got a saying around ramsay have
since i started this place when your
spirit leaves you should take your butt
with it
and uh because people stay sticking
around at a place where they're no
longer care no longer plugged in
they're they're they have their eyes on
the future they've already moved on uh
it's it's very difficult to not say
negative things it's very difficult to
uh not roll your eyes it's very
difficult to
you know bring it you mail it in instead
and all of that so people working on a
two-week notice around here we do it a
little bit we'll do three days or four
days to get stuff transitioned but uh we
accept the two-week notice and that's a
classy thing to offer it but seldom do
we work them out at ramsey we just when
your butt leaves you i'll take your
spirit with it so but you go in and talk
to those two guys and treat them like
men and women and grown-ups and you be a
grown-up and i think you'll find a way
to do this with great honor because
you're a man of honor yeah see the flip
side of this though dave is is when you
begin to feel a sense of guilt that's
coming from a place of a completely
false narrative guilt is usually a legal
term that says you've done something
wrong or you're accused of doing
something wrong didn't do anything wrong
you didn't do anything wrong here and so
that's the first step the second thing
is is what if you felt so guilty that
you you turned down a great opportunity
for your family 25 pay raise a better
401 k home with the kids i mean that's
the trifecta and you turn that down all
because you
think you're going to be a jerk and
you're really worried about what
somebody's going to say about you if you
leave them then you're going to be
what's known as an unhappy employee
you're going to be resentful you're
going to be miserable and you're going
to have your eye over on the other
opportunity all the time and this thing
is already going downhill it just
doesn't serve well here's the point i'm
making people feel like doing something
good for themselves is selfish
now when it is at the
plight of someone else or of course it's
selfish but there's nothing selfish in
this so we've got to get over this idea
that
bettering our lives is something we
should feel bad for i i really other
other than the pit of hell dave i don't
know where that comes from
it's straight from the pit of hell okay
i mean it really is this idea that you
better yourself uh well you should feel
guilty yeah it's it's it's a bit
freudian for sure yeah yeah that you
this idea that there's a cloud hanging
over your head it's like oh i i finally
have had something good happen
you know no but that's not this guy he's
just this guy's just trying to be a man
of integrity he's trying to be a man of
honor and i appreciate that so there's a
way you could do it
with a little bit of gentleness a little
bit of stretch in there
get that four week notice get a little
raise while you're doing that and then
let your current employer your former
employer
make the decisions on how quickly this
all goes down and you will you will have
been honorable and you made your call
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us jenny
is on the line in orlando florida hi
jenny how are you hey thank you so much
for taking my call
i am a little late to the day's party
um for context i um got divorced in 2020
and
i was really worried about budgeting and
one of my friends turned me on to total
money makeover
um i'm about to possibly make a big
decision
um i
bought a new house well i bought a house
when i moved to orlando
and
i give a 30-year mortgage
but i've been paying extra towards my
principal every single month
so i've got
12 i just made my 12th payment
and thinking about taking a healthy
chunk out of savings
and i've read a lot of conflicting
information
um
but then i look at how much
interest i would pay
versus how much interest i'm
earning
in my high yield
savings account a high yield savings
account is kind of a joke that's like
not really high and not really yield
it's like anything higher than a bank i
know but it's like you know what is it a
quarter of a percent or something
no it's like 0.7 oh
point seven
didn't even get all the way to one huh
where are the streamers yeah please i
want the fireworks to go off now
yeah so okay and your mortgage is what
three or four
so my mortgage is 2.625 yeah okay
and it was a 30-year
i've already paid down
uh 27.5
everything extra that i get how much is
in your savings at 0.7
um
savings was 95 933
95 000
yes okay
and what do you make a year giving
everything away and what do you make a
year
um 88. do you have any other debt
um i don't want to say it out loud
because you might have an aneurism
monthly maintenance on a timeshare oh
here we go okay we're still going with
time shares okay
all right the time shirt is paid off
good do you have any other day
do you have any other debt no okay good
all right and do you have an emergency
fund in addition to the 95 000 or does
that include your emergency fund
so that includes my my three to six
months what do you think your three to
six month emergency fund should be
i'm taking around
50 000
that might be a little steep but i'll go
with that okay so let's put let's put
let's put 50 000 on your mortgage how
much is your mortgage balance
so my mortgage balance right now is
uh
89.71
great okay i'm gonna put 50 on it and
then i'm going to pay it off in the next
two years
okay
now here's the thing you just you just
listen
you just got a 4 rate of return and you
thought high yield at 0.7 was good so we
just got you a 3.6 percent rate of
return pay and i'll pan down on that 50
000. the other money's going to sit
there's your emergency fund and then
you're going to pay the rest of this off
here's why i'm telling you to do this
because here's what's important it's not
the getting out of that thing that's
important
it's what getting out of debt does for
you
when you have no house payment
in the world
no payment in the world all you have and
you have an eighty eight thousand dollar
ninety thousand dollar income
you are going to become very wealthy
it's that simple
because now if you pay yourself a house
payment into a mutual fund in a few
years that's a million dollars
it doesn't take that long
and you're not that old how old are you
i'm 55. yeah i didn't think you were
very good okay i just i sound like i'm
12 no that's okay no i really i really
thought that's what i was thinking
you're probably in your 50s but not by
the sound of your voice but by what's
going on in your life so uh i think that
uh you know so 20 years from today when
you're 75 you're gonna have a net worth
of two million dollars uh 700 800 000 of
that will be this paid for house and 1.3
will be what's in your mutual funds
that's my prediction for you i think
you're going to be a baby steps
millionaire you're on your way and
that's why i'm telling you to do this
because as we've studied millionaires we
find they primarily become millionaires
with two main elements a paid for house
and a loaded up retirement account in
good mutual funds and the first one to
five million dollars of net worth that
people do as they become wealthy doing
dave ramsey i know some of you idiots
out there think people don't get wealthy
doing dave ramsey but they get wealthy
every day doing dave ramsey
and so
if you don't believe that you're an
idiot because i've led more people into
millionaire status than just about
anybody else on this planet
and so you walk this stuff out you play
these baby steps you get your house paid
off you build up your retirement
accounts you're going to end up with
millions of dollars now you're not going
to end up with 200 million you're not
going to be bill gates or jeff bezos
that's not what i'm teaching you to do
but i'm teaching you to become a
millionaire so you retire with dignity
and you change your family tree and you
get control of your freaking life and
you're going to do all of that you're
amazing you've done a great job hold on
we're going to have the team pick up and
send you a copy of baby steps
millionaire that's what i would do if i
woke up in your shoes i think she's cool
she's amazing remember she got an 88 000
income on top of this and she just went
through a divorce two years ago yeah so
you're right she's going to be able to
pay that house off quickly she's going
to be able to replenish that emergency
fund thirty nine thousand dollars left
on the house 89.00 today we put 50 on
this 39 left says 20 a year
20 a year over two years coming out of
88 you can pay 20 a year yes okay you
could probably pay 40 a year and be done
with it in one year if you want to beans
and rice it a little bit but i'm not
even saying do that have a great life
and still pay it off in two years she'll
be 57 years old with a paid for house
come on touchdown yeah
i like that i mean it's it's this is
very exciting and you love the intensity
mike's in boston hey mike what's up
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
go straight to your point so we don't
run out of time i want ken to answer
your question
okay um straight to my point is i have a
i have a job i make about 52 000 a year
and i was offered a job
for a little bit more maybe three or
four dollars an hour but with the
present job i i could get like 10 or 15
hours overtime uh and i make quite a bit
more i mean where do you draw the line
between
you know uh
how much you can make in quality of life
so the new job's going to give you a
better quality of life but not make as
much money is that what i'm hearing
yeah it would be more per hour but
you know much
um there's going to be less money over
the year you know i know maybe i should
just read paycheck the purpose huh
well it's a good idea
but here let's just let's just break
this down
what is the overtime
let's take the money out of the equation
what is the overtime doing to you
physically emotionally relationally
well physically i mean it's tiring but
you know i'm i'm a pretty strong guy
yeah you can hear broad shoulders i can
handle it i'll although you know i mean
it's very like a a year ago i tried to
take piano lessons but i couldn't
because i couldn't find somebody that
had an erratic schedule like that right
so there's a hobby that you can't do is
it is it affecting your family life in a
very negative way
no no so it's a toss-up so here's the
deal how old are you yeah
uh 55 when you're 65 10 years from now
which of these are you gonna be glad you
did
uh well i'd have a lot more money right
when i'm 65 than right now but yeah but
let me tell you this you're limiting
yourself if i keep doing this over time
right i think there's your answer so
i've number one i think you're limiting
yourself that this
new opportunity that's been offered to
you is the is the only opportunity for
you to do something where life balance
if you will is a little bit better um
but you're limited financially i just
think that's the wrong way to look at
this i i think this opportunity is is
one for you to not just take it just yet
but look into what are some other
opportunities that might be out there if
i'm patient um but i here's the ultimate
decision
i think you got to sit down with your
family
and you've got to decide good
old-fashioned grandmas pros and cons
and follow your heart what is your heart
telling you to do this isn't a big
financial difference here this is not
something that i would be stewing over
and making it this big huge decision i
don't think it's that financially i do
think it's a big decision for you in
your quality of life and dave i thought
that question is
that really leads to the hard answer 10
years from now what decision i kind of
like i kind of like c none of the above
go find something making five thousand
dollars a year on forty years oh that's
what i suggested i want him to look at
that before he goes after this
we had that caller in the other hour
that went from fifty to a hundred
thousand
in fifteen months because she went after
it cause she went after it she said i
want more money shake the apple tree
mike i think that might be the strategy
see what happens and hang on we'll send
you a copy of from paycheck to purpose
bestseller by ken coleman show you how
to do it and it's our gift to you
brother thanks for listening
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host thank you for joining us america
this is the ramsay show live from the
headquarters of ramsey solutions
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i am dave ramsey we're going to
talk to you about your mental health
about your jobs about your boundaries
about your relationships about your
money
yeah we talk about everything here right
in front of you triple eight eight two
five five
five carrie is in chicago hi carrie
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave hi ken thanks so much for taking
my call we appreciate so much what you
guys do well thank you how can we help
so hopefully this will be a quick
question um
our family is in baby steps four five
and six um last year we started in hsa
we've got about fifty one hundred
dollars in that right now
um and just kind of wanting to get your
thoughts on when you recommend investing
your hsa and what you recommend
investing it in
we use a company called health equity
that allows us to put our hsas into
mutual funds
and we recommend to our team and i
personally put mine all in mutual funds
because i don't use them
if you think you're going to use your
hsa
to pay medical bills or deductibles or
whatever
are you know by medical services which
you can certainly do if you're actually
going to use it for that
then um
then you probably don't want to put it
in mutual funds you probably want to put
keep enough of it anyway in in simple
money market type accounts that it's
accessible because you don't want you
know what you don't want to put ten
thousand dollars in there and then the
stock market go down be worth eight
thousand dollars by the time you have a
medical event
right right and we're a pretty healthy
bunch we don't really
we really haven't had to use it at all
yeah well we've yeah and also the thing
about where you are in your baby steps
you've got the income probably to cover
whatever you need
right yeah our max out of pocket per
year would be about seven thousand
dollars um with our plan so i just
would it make sense to leave at least
that in there as liquid cash and then
invest the rest because our company does
give us two thousand dollars a year
that'd be fun and then we we put in the
mac yeah that'd be fine okay and in
effect that's what i have done i've got
like a couple hundred thousand bucks in
there
because i i started doing it when uh
bush first uh george w first came out
with it was under his administration
that's how long it's been around and i
fully funded the hsa every single year
since then and i've never touched it
so any time we're a pretty healthy bunch
too knock on wood but anytime we've had
a medical anything i just wrote check
for it
and i left my investments alone okay and
so i've always had it in good mutual
funds and it's always grown and in a
sense it just becomes another ira of
sorts
great right and so yeah and where the
company's giving you an extra two grand
that's awesome have at it yeah because
that adds up pretty quickly it has i
mean it turned into like a serious money
i mean it's real yeah so um a couple of
hundred grand yeah there we go i'm gonna
have to tell stacey we're not taking the
kids to the doctor
a little note here yeah just just
draw a hot bath we're saving our money
yeah there's some epsom salts go knock
yourself out
steve's in oklahoma city steve babson
salt how are you
how are you steve
i was not too bad good
all right quick situation for you okay
so there's 250 000 sitting it's my
mother's money
she's um on disability living with
a brother has been for about a year
and my other brother has liquidated
everything and money is just sitting
cash in the bank
and we're trying to figure out how to
keep it from going to medicaid in case
she was to need to go into a facility
situation you can't medicaid is for poor
people
it's welfare okay or
okay and she's not on welfare she's got
a quarter of a million dollars
so if you transfer this money in order
to hide it and get welfare
that's called welfare fraud
it's called medicaid fraud
so your mom your mom should not want to
go into your mom should not want to go
into a welfare nursing home
right right
okay
and you shouldn't want for her to
so you guys we don't we're just trying
to figure out and she said she's got
dementia
um it's a kind of a horn of dementia
basically okay all right well what i
would do is i would use i would make
sure the money's invested i wouldn't
just leave it in an account i'd put it
in some good mutual funds and if you do
that it'll throw off a couple thousand
dollars a month and i would bring in
some help to help your brother
and help take care of her get some
in-home care you can actually provide
nursing home services
in his home
with outside help
almost as cheap as you can hire a nurse
as you can buy a nursing home if not
cheaper depending on how you structure
it if he's willing to do all of that and
willing to put up with
nurses coming and going and and cares
caregivers coming and going and you know
it's it's a hassle but you know this
money will support her and take care of
her
she'll be fine
well that's what it's for it was just
was i wasn't sure if there was a amount
of time that that outweighed that they
would take the money or not yeah five
years
if you move it and if you move it and
she does not go into nursing home for
five years and she is a presents herself
as a poor person who needs welfare to be
put on medicaid and go into medicaid
nursing home
they won't they look back on it as five
years
so after five years the money's released
after giving away after five years the
money will no longer be
if you move the money into you and your
brother's name five years later
five years later they won't look back
and you can put your mother in a welfare
nursing home
oh okay
all right i think that's immoral by the
way i think that's immoral right yeah
i i understand okay i'm just making sure
you understand where i stand on it you
do whatever you want to do but i i think
that's wrong your mother has a quarter
of a million dollars it's there for her
care it's not for you and your brother
it's for her she saved money her whole
life and she it's there to take care of
her uh and by the way if she is at this
level of care the average nursing home
stay in america is 2.3 years
and the average nursing home cost in
america is 55 000 a year
okay so that's a hundred thousand bucks
150 000 bucks for the 250 you guys will
still have 100 left over for your
inheritance on average that's what
you're facing
now if you you can go buy a nursing home
for 150 a year too
and you can go buy a nursing home for
whatever but um i i
you know the reason we work the reason
we save money is to care for ourselves
not to be on the government dole
and the quality of care is different the
experience is different for your mom
this is your you know your mom ought to
ought to be treated like a queen
uh not a welfare recipient she's got a
quarter of a million dollars
and that's that's how that's how i view
it so again you guys do whatever you
want to do and you called here so
that's the thing so
the nursing home thing is weird it's
like the nursing home is going to take
our money we don't say that when we go
to a restaurant they're going to take my
money we say no i'm going to give you
some money so i get food when you go to
nursing homes you say i'm gonna give you
money so i get care
they're not taking your money they're
not thieves they don't have a gun
you know it's not it's not
but there's something in the american
brain that feels like nursing homes
being paid is unfair yeah
and they shouldn't be paid it's weird
it's just weird
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian health care
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well i suspect by now your new year's
resolutions have run out
if you had resolutions they're usually
gone by about valentine's day
because people trying to do it on your
own with no plan and no no proven
process
usually these things are just wishes
they're not goals they're not
resolutions they're just wishes
well instead we want you to actually be
able to pull this money thing off
actually get it done we want you to work
the process and become a baby steps
millionaire like the latest best seller
you can do this by joining a financial
peace university class
about 10 million folks have been through
this class
it works we not only show you how to get
out of debt we show you how to become
wealthy
and many many people when they follow
the plan do well everyone that follows
the plan all the way through becomes
wealthy a hundred percent of the time
just a matter how long it takes and how
much you get
uh you know i can't tell if it's gonna
be 10 million or one million but you're
going to end up wealthy
and it's not it's not a magic pill and
it's not a get rich quick it's hard
but we get you out of debt we get your
teach you about insurance we teach you
about investing it's the money class you
should have had back when you're in high
school but nobody hardly teaches it in
high school until we start teaching at
night school financial peace university
in person and online it's the proven
money plan you can do a free trial at
ramsey plus if you want to check it out
go to ramseysolutions.com
fpu for financial peace university
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu
this is the ramsey show
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host lisa is with us in new york city
hi lisa welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
well i've listened for years i've paid
thousands of dollars in debt and i'm at
a point where i have my six-month
emergency fund
i'm probably putting about 14 in
retirement i just have my mortgage as my
debt they're amazing well done
yeah thanks to you for keeping me all
those days on the road i work in sales
so
i listen to you pretty much every time i
got in the car wow um
but anyways i'm planning to leave the
corporate world i feel like god is
calling me into
a different direction healing arts and i
as they prepare my exit plan from that
um career
i'm wondering what advice you have over
the next few months should i be saving
some a certain amount more money should
i
cut back on what i'm putting in my 401k
for a little bit what do you suggest as
i prepare that exit strategy so to speak
um
well the main thing i want you to do is
get the boat close enough to the dock
that it's not a leap it's a step
meaning that as you move into this other
income go ahead and have that income
going can we do that
i think so but i think it might come to
the point where
the company i'm working for is having
major financial problems so
it might not be so much of a choice
they're having major financial problems
now
it's
uh
i don't really want to get into all of
it but yes there's some it might be
sooner than later okay well lisa i'm
gonna jump in really quick we don't want
this dream i'm assuming this this
business you want to start is this a
dream job for you something you really
want to do personally
yeah it is
my calling yeah all right so here's the
deal we don't rely on that
running away yeah but listen you're the
current company being a financial
problem isn't the impetus
to start and try to make it full-time in
this calling dave's right you need to
start the calling the side business
that's what it needs to be we're going
to test it start small grow slow uh grow
i am planning to do that i know but what
i'm saying is i know but being smart is
if your current company's having
financial problems we need another day
job as a backup you understand what i'm
saying okay
you don't want to put yourself you're in
such good financial shape
you could kill a dream faster than any
other way of to kill a dream by putting
all the financial pressure on it to
provide for you when it's something
you're starting that's a really big red
flag
what do you do now
i work in sales okay and what are you
going to be doing
what's your what's your dream your
business you want to start
uh it has a lot of components but
healing arts
healing heart break that down for us
neither one of us how do you make money
doing this teach me about it
i will be teaching people how to use art
for their
therapy
i'm also going to be selling some of my
artwork
okay
and to date you've not done this yet in
any future
you have okay and so how much money have
you made to date
i
have been just kind of doing it on the
side i'm i'm not talking i'm going to do
this tomorrow i'm saying as i prepare
myself i'm saying i'm not i'm going to
be smart about it like trust me i've you
know i've been trying i'm trying
so far i misunderstood where you were so
how much have you made doing how much do
you make doing healing arts right now
i make about 130 000 doing healing arts
no no no i'm asking about the healing
arts business
i'm not making any money yet i'm telling
you i'm trying to prepare myself for
that okay
so
what are they doing should be feeling
extra money you need to have a big pile
of money but there's not a big enough
pile of money for you to jump from
something to nothing
and so the way you prepare is you get
the healing arts business going right
now as a side hustle and gear it up as
fast as you can
and and if it can if you can get to
making 60 or 70 thousand dollars you can
exist on that where you used to make 100
at the old job while then this night
this dream doesn't turn into a nightmare
on you but if you've got 200 000 saved
up and you burn through it because you
make zero for two years after quitting
your full-time corporate job or losing
the full-time corporate job because the
company collapsed and you didn't have a
day job that's what ken's talking about
so the way to prepare is not the size of
the
the the uh
savings account the savings account
it is the size of the income from the
side hustle that's right that's what
that's what i mean by pulling the boat
alongside so it wasn't the way you
thought we were gonna answer the
question you wanted an answer of how
much money you need to be prepared to
move i mean you could have i guess you
could have two million dollars and not
burn through it unless you burn through
a million a year but i you know that's
not these aren't options that are on
your table so
let's just say
that um
the most important part of the equation
is to get the side income approaching
the current income the closer it is to
the current income the less risk you
would have and obviously the less burn
rate on a savings account you would have
yeah i i think lisa the first step for
me is i'm beginning to look in the
marketplace in new york city uh you're a
salesperson a successful sales person
i'd be looking at other companies that
aren't struggling financially so that i
could move into a more stable day job so
that i'm not putting pressure on the
dream job the side hustle that's what
i'm getting at i think that's the first
sure save money great keep saving
but
i want you
when you're saying you're working for a
company struggling financially i'd be
looking for a plan b
for the day job in case in case that
happened that's right the income is more
of a problem than the savings that's
correct and the savings that's what
we're trying to get to so good luck with
it i hope it works out for you and thank
you for listening we i think you've done
a great job to get to the point you are
by the way you've done a really really
good job very very well done i want to
recommend a quick little book to her
dave quick read by austin cleon it's
called show your work and you can read
it in 10 minutes but it's it's really
important for entrepreneurs and
entrepreneur want to bees that are
trying to get something going uh and
it'll really encourage you just to kind
of get your stuff out there
people focus on business plans too much
and things like this in the early stages
as opposed to just showing their work
getting their work out there letting the
letting the marketplace tell you
how this is working around here
around here the way i teach our team is
uh have a conversation with the
marketplace the marketplace will say
you're doing really good and that looks
like green president's faces
or the marketplace will say you suck and
it will like we buy nothing you put out
there sound like crickets and i've had
both by the way yeah um sometimes the
marketplace says to me entire company
you suck you're doing a bad job we're
not going to give you any money and
other times they say wow you changed our
lives and we're not only going to give
you money we're going to tell everybody
else to come and and get this service or
this teaching or this content or
whatever it is and that's how 10 million
people went through financial peace
university but the uh but the ideas that
we've tried around here where the
marketplace looked back at us and said
you suck now here's the problem
when you
become desperate
and you start launching products out of
desperation or services out of
desperation because you need money
that puts a strain on it and the
marketplace can smell that you smell
different
you have a stink on you when you're
broke
and so that's why i tell folks all the
time try to start your business as a
side hustle pull the boat up next to the
dock and then step in don't take a leap
of faith that's only in the movies this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america in the lobby of ramsey solutions
on the debt free stage andy and julie
are with us hey guys how are you hi dave
doing great welcome where do you guys
live wyoming minnesota ah welcome to
nashville now where is wyoming minnesota
uh 30 minutes north of st paul oh okay
okay cool all right fun yeah we've been
to eagle church up there a bunch of
times so close beautiful area yeah very
nice that church has been very good to
us over the years good folks well fun
very fun welcome to nashville how much
debt have you paid
178 000 all right good for you and how
long did that take uh 26 months whoa and
your range of income during that time we
started off at 110 000 and finished at
150.
okay
did you sell something big
no we no
no we did have um we had a
chunk of change that you threw at it
okay so you had some savings how much
savings did you have to throw at it um
about thirty thousand yeah okay i guess
it's 140 is still just there's still 70.
you're still on beans and rice yeah yeah
pretty tight wow cool what kind of debt
was this
um two vehicles and then we paid off our
house
people
love it what's this house worth about
420.
and it's all yours that's right way to
go you guys i can't wait to mow the
grass now this year when it's mine now
that it's mine and i own it
that's so cool way to go you guys thank
you way to go and you did this really
fast yeah i mean the intensity here in
these numbers that's what i was trying
to go
try and run the numbers in my head there
oh my gosh so tell me the story what
happened 26 months ago set you on fire
it's just a lot of youtube watching dave
yeah we just thought
this is something we should do and we
just wanted to make sure
our future is secure you just stumbled
into us on youtube yeah
i i had heard of you um through our
church actually i had heard of your name
but i just kind of feared that i had
things figured out and i never really
looked into you and i stumbled across
you on youtube
and
he came home one night from work and i
said oh you got to check this guy out
you're going to love him
and i did we were yeah we were hooked
like saturday night we just would watch
you and oh my gosh
yeah you just he knew that the value
system was similar and you're like okay
this guy this guy's going to get us out
of debt we're going to we're going to go
on and be wealthy that's right yeah i
love it my husband's old school and good
old boy just like you so yeah okay yeah
all right
okay all right yeah i knew i had a
cousin in minneapolis yeah that's right
i will say he has a better head of hair
dave well that's a low bar
way to go you guys i'm so proud of you
how's it feel to be completely free it's
amazing you can do whatever we want now
yeah really paycheck comes we get to
keep it how long you all been married uh
since 2010 okay so 12 years yup have you
ever been debt-free in your adult life
i haven't
i was except a mortgage
so yeah but then we got married and kind
of just
we weren't out of control or anything um
we just
when i found you we just realized that
we were still in step two because we had
two vehicle loans
and we kind of felt good about having
that
you know savings account
and so i can relate to the callers that
call in and you tell them well you got
money to just
you know pay it off and
there's just a silence like well that's
everything that i have in the bank right
now
yeah yeah oh it just got real yeah yeah
yeah so we just watched you a lot and
one day he came home from work another
day and i said you know let's do this
plan let's do this plan we we have
enough to just pay off the vehicles and
kind of go down to that you know small
emergency fund yeah there wasn't much
left
yeah then it was go time yeah yeah
what did that look like because i mean
these numbers are extraordinary and when
dave asked you a minute ago you pretty
much rise to beats andy you were like
like like you hit a nerve there like how
intense was it i want people to get a
picture how much did you sacrifice you
know it wasn't really that hard because
we're kind of frugal to begin with and
uh you know just not eating out lunch a
lot at work and
you know we don't do a lot of things
that are extraordinary extravagant so it
was it was kind of easy for us
to see in the picture when she made a
picture of the squares for the house
being paid off that was really big for
me uh just watching the watching that
happen and you know seeing it at the
bottom and once he got to the middle and
you know he just got closer every day
and it was just it was really fun to
watch it and sometimes she called me and
say i filled in 10 more squares and i'm
like what
but that was that was our goal was to
you know take all the extra money at it
and hit it you know so nothing was hard
about it you just told us this was easy
it wasn't bad okay so you're just really
disciplined i've been frugal my whole
life so
um i mean i was like the weird teenager
that worked and saved money to go to
college
i went to college debt-free look at you
dave the bass in minnesota don't care if
i have a thousand dollar boat i found
that out
nice
i should have put a boat in there
because yeah we've got like a thousand
dollar boat for the last eight years or
whatever and we still have it and we're
happy with it yeah
no plans to replace that anytime soon
well you can if you want now that's
right you've got the money with cash
yeah way to go you guys so proud of you
so proud of you so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of debt is
what was the thing that because you were
already smart you already had common
sense you already went to school
debt-free you are already frugal but
something clicked what was the
difference that made you go all right
game on
for me it was just seeing the show and
hearing people do it you know and seeing
the results that they had and how happy
they were when they were here
that was a big thing for me yeah yeah
and for me it was because i thought that
i was doing pretty good it was just
looking at the baby steps and realizing
that we were doing like a bunch of
things at the same time
because we were we were even paying
towards extra toward the house in the
beginning and we were doing a little bit
of retirement and just but we were just
doing a little bit of everything
and
you know like when he came home and i
said let's just do the baby steps
because it's just so much more
it's just a clear path it's simple
anyone can do it and it just makes sense
and all these people have done it
so how much do you guys have in your
investments
north of 100 right now but we're going
to be ramping that up
yeah you'll be able to yeah yeah yeah
for sure so you'll be baby steps
millionaires in no time yeah way to go
you guys yeah way to go i'm so proud of
you very very well done good stuff all
right we got a copy of that book for you
baby steps millionaires to finish this
journey that's the next step in uh next
uh chapter in your story for sure also a
copy total money makeover for you to
give away to somebody somebody's been
wondering what happened to these people
they've been smiling a lot
so they want to know what happened to
them you know this is very cool you guys
very well done all right it's andy and
julie minneapolis minnesota 178 000 paid
off house and everything
did it in 26 months making 110 to 150
through a little savings at it and got
after it count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one we're debt-free
yeah
man oh man oh man
that's the uh
second debt free scream that we've had
on today
and both of them said the same thing
about different subjects
it was almost like they uh there was a a
little bit of an epiphany they said you
know our first one the lady said you
know she went from 50 to 100 000 income
i said how'd you do that she said i just
wanted more money i went and got it yep
and it's like they just look up and go
this is possible yep when someone looks
up and they're getting a new job in your
world
you know they're they're uh
going to deal with boundary issues in
daloni's world they're gonna get out of
debt over here bill wealth become
millionaires in our world you know
wherever we are in ramsey when people
look up and they think it's possible we
call that hope yes
and hope is a big deal hope fuels
everything because if you think you can
or you think you can't you're right
henry ford said that's right and that's
the truth well you've talked about this
a lot at our money events you know you
you demonstrate it with a clap but what
you're really illustrating is they just
decide right now and when he came home
that day she looked at him they've been
watching youtube and she went
let's just do this yeah there wasn't any
like which means it can be done it can
be nice so they were already like once i
realized it can be done and then you go
why wouldn't i you just decided why
wouldn't i there you go change as dave
says why wouldn't i why wouldn't i go
double my income why wouldn't i pay off
my house yeah that's right why wouldn't
i once i believe i can
yeah that's hope why wouldn't i
hope is powerful hope deferred makes the
heart sick but when desire comes
it is the tree of life this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today our scripture of the day
is isaiah 43 2. when you pass through
the waters i will be with you and when
you pass through the rivers they will
not sweep over you when you walk through
the fire you will not be burned the
flames will not set you ablaze
billy graham said courage is contagious
when a brave man takes a stand
the spines of others are often stiffened
billy graham you gotta love him pretty
cool
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five marquee is with
us in madison wisconsin hey marquis how
are you
i am doing well i am more than honored
to be speaking to you guys it's
like a dream thank you guys for
everything you too sir how can we help
thank you so i
am
from
a kind of a a rougher area
um
my mom raised three of us by herself
uh so i've never really so she's always
she's listened to you before but she's
never had the needs to really fully
commit
and
neither have i so i've listened to you
for a while but now i finally
got my uh
job out of school so i'm in a
i did an internship over this past
summer and it led to a role which gave
me a real salary which i'm doing that on
top of being a single dad and doing
masters so
basically what i'm asking you is where
do where do i begin
because i've been listening to you for a
while and i never called because i never
had the means for
the knowledge to call you and now i'm
just
ready to commit and hopefully even teach
this stuff someday wow well i'm honored
what do you what do you do for a living
now
so i am a
service operations supervisor for a
health plan so we do insurance and stuff
like that like claims customer service
what do you make um
65. good for you good and you just
finished a four-year degree and you're
working on a master's
dual master so i'm the first at my
school to ever attempt to do it so they
created the program because i requested
it uh it's executive mba
and uh healthcare administration masters
so i'll do both how are you paying for
it uh student loans at the moment never
had the funds to
how far into it how far into the dual
master's are you
about a semester a little bit over a
semester because i took a
summer course as well okay all right
well there's a lot going on here in this
conversation um
congratulations i'm proud of you you've
made incredible progress you've broken
through a lot of seedlings a lot of
barriers to get to where you are i'm
proud of you and i think you're going to
go to incredible places
the only question is what's the best
vehicle the best method
for you to get to those wonderful places
and what i'm always looking for is the
uh
the quickest right way
uh to get you to your goal you know and
that's what we're always looking for in
these situations
and so in ken's case where you're
working with education
the question is do you need a dual
masters is that the quickest right way
to get to your goal
and um
uh
you know it may or may not be
but right now it sounds like that for
the first time in your life and for that
matter in a couple of generations you're
actually making a living
yes and that's like that's like a new
experience the way you described it
absolutely so that's why i'm just saying
i don't even know how i'm gonna pay for
the uh
the financial piece but i'm all on board
not just yeah i'm ready
well um you know
the first thing that occurs to me and
i'm just going to say it out loud and
you you get you're a grown person you
get to make your decisions
but um
i wish you would rest a little bit
before you dove into debt to go get this
dual degree and just enjoy making 65 or
75 000 a year yes for a little while
and then figure out where you are
uh do you have student loan debt from
your undergrad
uh yeah i have about a total of like 40k
that's all it was because i didn't go to
a bigger school i also had some
scholarships for uh good show let me
tell you what we have discovered as we
work with the student loan industry and
with people that get student loan debt
and i've run into this all over the
place
the vast majority of people who make big
student loan mistakes
are first generation college students
meaning their mom and dad did not go to
college
and that doesn't mean they're evil but
mom and dad there was no one around to
say hey don't go that far in debt to do
that it's not worth it
no one no because like i went to college
i was the first generation went to
college i didn't but student loans
weren't around much when i was there so
when my kids got ready to go to school
you know they could go to a super
expensive school
and we didn't we could have paid for it
or they went to a state school in our
case and we could have paid for it but
we could guide them because they hadn't
we had been there before so and
sometimes what happens in a situation
like you described is you start thinking
that all education is worth whatever it
costs
and it's worth whatever amount of debt
you go into for yeah and i disagree it's
not yeah
all education is not smart that's an odd
statement but all education is not smart
so marquis i'm going to recommend that
you push your put your uh master's
program on hold a little bit
and you take at least a few semesters
off uh and you may not do that because
you may be plugged into this but i think
you're looking for something in this
dual masters that's not there yeah
you think so yeah so marquis
we could hear it in your voice you
don't want to live financially the way
that you had to grow up and you've done
a great job and you've been very
successful getting to this point you're
making good money and if you follow
financial peace and the baby steps
here's the deal i agree with dave in
fact i would go a little stronger i
would press
uh
pause on the master's degree until
we get out of debt
and until you compete until you can pay
cash for it so that might be two or
three years but it might be your company
will pay your debt that's exactly right
but mark here's the deal here's what i
want to hear um
because we'll walk you through the
financial stuff but here's the deal
those master's degrees will still be
there when you get out of debt they will
still be there the opportunities that
might be attached to those master's
degrees will still be there but i think
where you're in now if you're doing a
great job and you see what the latter
might look like in your company i think
you could get a couple promotions make
more money without those master's
degrees and get out of debt faster walk
through the baby steps and really get
financially sound and then ask the
question
do the master's degrees get me the is it
the only way to get me where i want to
go if the answer is no then you don't
have to ever go back but the point is
you're not saying no now you're going
pause
pause pause pause pause
yeah
so um
yeah hold on we're going to sign you up
and put you into ramsey plus for free
for a year i'm gonna pay for it i want
you to go to financial peace university
i want you to go through the classes i
want you to get on the every dollar app
i want you to consume every piece of
content in there
and we'll show you how to handle money
young man we'll get you we'll we'll be
the will be part of the story of you
changing your whole family tree and
because that's what you're all about
you're all about changing your family
tree and that's no dis that's not
disrespecting or dishonoring your mom
she was a tough warrior princess she
fought and raised kids and scraped and
worked her tail end off and got you to
where you are so we want to honor her
and we want to say you're going to take
it past there you're going to go to
another level and so and we'll show you
how
but again so that hang on and we'll have
the team pick up and get you signed up
so folks here's what i want you hear
loud and clear
those masters that he's taking are good
fields of study
they may or may not roi depending on
what he's paying for them we didn't ask
that but he doesn't have the money to go
that's right
and what i want to break among all of
you out there whether you're
first-generation college students or
whether you're not whether your mom and
dad went to school or whether they
didn't
whether they went to whether you're the
seventh generation to go to school
we have to break this thing that says
all education is worth whatever you pay
for it
that is absolutely asinine
this is how we have people paying two
hundred twenty five dollar thousand
dollars to get a master's degree in
social work so they get a thirty eight
thousand dollar job working for the
state as a social worker
and because they got a master's in
sociology that's just asinine
okay that's stupid
and we've got to quit being stupid about
education now he's not in that situation
but this is the kind of thing that
people do when they believe that all
education is good all education is worth
whatever you pay for it and so people
spend 200 grand getting a degree in
left-handed puppetry and it's useless
don't do that he's not on that bubble
but he's getting close
that puts us out of the ramsey show in
the books we'll be back with you before
you know it in the meantime remember
there's ultimately only one way to
financial peace and that's to walk daily
with the prince of peace christ jesus
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you